hey this is Ted Lange executive producer
at reverb triple XP we are showing off
the game Phoenix rage it's coming out
sep tember 24th for pc on steam british
show up a whole bunch of new features
new game modes for example here's the
challenge mode challenge mode is really
interesting that I mean Phoenix reja for
anyone it has seen it is very hardcore
type of game what challenge mode will
actually do is give you the exact kind
of the perfect run so right here if you
see in the the top corner you have a
limited number of jumps and once you
reach that limit restart so these are
really for those perfectionists they're
gonna have a great time with this
because you're going to learn how to get
kind of perfect your skills hone them in
so that you can impress your friends and
kind of show up on the global
leaderboards which is going to be a big
thing I think seeing everybody fighting
over them and kind of getting your
bragging rights it's going to be really
fun here we have god mode god mode is
actually a whole new game mode you can
play through the entire game a
completely different way so after being
tortured and punished by all these
little green guys throughout the your
first playthrough now you have this blue
flame that you're able to destroy all of
them but you do have to do it in a
limited time so although you're
invincible it still proves to be very
very challenging but similar to the main
game it's all about completion so
there's opportunities to just complete
it without getting the good time without
just getting it perfect so that you can
move on but you always have something to
go back to to to improve on so how you
unlock these modes is throughout the
game you're going to be earning cookies
and the cookies you can use to unlock
secret cookie recipes that you'll see
I'm also you'll be unlocking
modes like the challenge mode from
playing through the main game and here
we see you get to unlock a whole bunch
of different cookies and these are
actual real world's cookies that you can
create yourself they were all tested
deliciously tested let me add my gut
agrees with most of these each one is
based around the level that you beat to
unlock it so in order to unlock each
cookie based on each world that you play
you have to collect the cookies in game
so in game cookies equal real world
cookies which is great I wish that
worked for the gold coins in Mario
Brothers through the main game you also
unlock stars which you can end up using
the unlock minigames and all sorts of
other little hidden features so it's
really playing through every aspect of
this game another little bonus is there
will be these little hidden red squares
that you'll find on certain levels when
you use when you find the red squares
and you get to them in a certain amount
of time you'll actually unlock some
prototype levels called them the Phoenix
box levels and these ones will give you
a little glimpse at how the game looked
when it was in the prototype stage
here's an example of one of those so you
can see very modern graphics some HD
1080p Atari but this is exactly how the
game was created really using just
simplistic graphics to really fine-tune
the mechanics because with a game like
this where it's so hard core and pixel
perfect it's really important that the
mechanics feel right so at no point is
it the game messing you up it's you made
the jump wrong you did the dash wrong so
that it really feels that the game is as
tight as possible and that's I think was
the most important thing for the
developers is making sure that it felt
right before really adding the polish of
the graphics and the sound and all those
elements and you also unlock a whole
bunch of little mini games hum these are
really just good to get a break from the
normal agonizing painful gameplay one
example is on the developers being from
Costa Rica and doing so great in the
World Cup this year there's a soccer
based level where it's all about kind of
keeping the the ball in the air getting
it as many times as possible and
obviously you compete for your high
score in this as well most things in the
game have leaderboards have things to
challenge your friends get those
bragging rights and really just show off
your skills a whole bunch of different
levels to play there's four different
worlds in the main game each with 20
levels and then there's also the Dark
Worlds which provide even more challenge
20 levels in each of those worlds and if
you can beat those then you unlock
sanctuary the final world which is
brutal let me tell you I I still can't
beat many many of these levels you'll
also notice there's a whole bunch of
different mechanics that you'll unlock
all along the way but the mechanics are
actually the world and level based so
you start off from the beginning with
every tool that Phoenix has and it's
really all about the levels whether
there's enemies or fire elements or ice
elements which help you solve the
puzzles of each level so very similar to
how a lot of old school games happen in
the nets and super nest days where your
character was your character and it was
really about figuring out how each world
is solved rather than upgrading your
characters and leveling them up so
here's a sample of a pretty easy level
off of the first world it's got fire
elements that you use to break the ice
bricks that provides definitely a lot of
challenge still but you'll see in a
second once you get into the dark world
version of these levels it's much much
different red forest becomes red dawn
and these levels now become quite a bit
tougher with new enemies new puzzles
these little alligator monster things
are the bane of my existence as soon as
they start getting your scent I mean
they follow you around faster than you
can zoom and jump and dash and all that
stuff
getting the cookie becomes even harder
on all these levels it's placed himself
very nicely in between and also if you
notice at the top of the screen you see
one of those red blocks that's exactly
how you unlock the the prototype levels
that are hidden throughout the game so
certain levels will have those when you
see the countdown timer so it's all
about reaching that block before the
countdown finishes to unlock those
levels the other thing that you'll
notice is that although the level real
we start for Phoenix himself when you
die the game is perpetually always
moving the the level itself doesn't
restart just where the player starts so
if a monster stops at a certain point
he's going to stay at that after you die
so you can kind of use that to your
advantage or disadvantage another little
tough trick thing on the Dark Worlds is
this one has a exit that teleports all
around so even though it's hard to
traverse these areas it makes it even
harder because you have to meet the
teleporter where it's at Phoenix rage is
coming out September 24th for PC on
Steam and multiple other retailers also
it's coming to Xbox one and ps4 in early
2015
you